okay hi everyone
i'm back for another episode of uh
science and technology q a
for kids and others and i noticed that
there are a few questions that got left
over from last time so maybe i can
start with some of those
so the first question i see is from z
hammer
what is the difference between fusion
and fission
so these are both stories about nuclear
physics
and what they're about they're both ways
to make energy from nuclei and
so nucleus of an atom is what's at the
center of the atom it's made of
basically protons and neutrons and uh
the different atoms the different types
of elements that are in the periodic
table hydrogen helium lithium beryllium
boron and so on
each separate kind of element has
progressively
one more proton so hydrogen has one
proton helium has two protons
lithium has three protons and so on all
the way up
to uh uranium which has
uh 92 protons and there are other
elements that go up to about 115
protons beyond that and each kind of
nucleus can have varying numbers of
neutrons as well
so the most common form of hydrogen most
common isotope of hydrogen
has one proton and zero neutrons but
there's also deuterium
which is one proton and one neutron
there's tritium which is one proton and
two neutrons
those are all three of those are
isotopes of hydrogen
they're all hydrogen because they all
have the same number of protons namely
one
they're different isotopes because they
have different numbers of neutrons
okay so that's atomic nuclei
um the uh what are fission infusion
so one thing is when you break an atomic
nucleus apart
it's hard to do because there's a strong
forces that
that uh hold together the protons and
neutrons in the nucleus if you break it
apart
if you break apart a uranium atom
with its like let's say 230 something
protons and neutrons in it if you break
it apart
it will make energy when you break it
apart somewhat confusingly
when you take uh if you take two uranium
atoms you try and smoosh them together
uh don't don't get energy by doing that
but if you take two hydrogen atoms
and you smoosh those together you get
energy
as those as uh as those combined into
another nucleus so what's happening in
in uh in fission that's breaking things
apart
you're taking a big nucleus and you're
breaking it in pieces
um to make smaller nuclei and you get
energy in that process
in fusion you're taking uh typically
smaller nuclei
and you're smushing them together and
getting energy in that process too
okay so now we have to try to explain
why it is the case well let's talk about
where fission and fusion show up
um and then we'll talk about why it's
the case that you both get energy by
fusing small nuclei and breaking apart
big nuclei
um so the uh
uh so first of all where do these things
show up
so uh fission
is what is was the original idea for
nuclear weapons
and it's what powers nuclear power
stations
and usually what happens is there's uh
one takes
uranium or plutonium um other
sometimes some other elements but
usually those two those are both
heavy elements with lots of protons and
neutrons
and uh you get energy in a nuclear
reactor for example
by having those nuclei get broken apart
so that's
an example of fission um the first
nuclear bombs
were made with fission uh using uranium
and plutonium
um that's another example of fission
okay fusion
the most famous place that fusion
happens as in stars like the sun
it's what makes the energy of of
something like the sun
is the fusion in the case of the sun
mostly of hydrogen nuclei
uh fusing together to make helium and so
on
you can also make hydrogen bombs that
actually are usually made with i think
lithium deuteride
um not strictly hydrogen but they're
there
those are fusion bombs and somewhat
again confusingly
you need the energy of a fission
explosion
to start a fusion bomb explosion
um and uh but fusion bombs work by
the so-called hydrogen bombs work by
again doing the same kind of thing that
the sun does
of of smooshing together small nuclei to
make energy
now people have been trying to make the
analog of nuclear power stations
with fusion for about 60 years now
um and trying to set it up so that you
kind of recreate
the conditions inside the sun very high
temperatures but but
um atoms having be having being pushed
together
they're trying to make it so that that
works in um
uh in in a in something like a power
station and there
are for a long time it was like this
just doesn't work
it's it's really hard to keep uh the
plasma
the very um the the uh just nuclei
without their electrons going around
them to keep that very uh
you know million degrees centigrade type
plasma or whatever it is
to keep it contained as opposed to just
squirting out in all directions
because to have it be the case that
these nuclei
can actually fuse you need them to get
rammed together hard enough
that this fusion process can actually
happen and in order to do that you have
to confine
these things in a in a sort of container
um that uh that can contain them now
question is what do you have what can
you get
that can contain a thing at a million
degrees for example
well the sun doesn't have that problem
because the sun is held together by
gravity the sun is very big
and held together by gravity so it's
it's
all of its hydrogen is all being pulled
together by the gravity of the sun
but if you're just in some backyard or
you know power station sized device
certainly the force of gravity doesn't
get to do that so you have to have some
way
to confine the plasma this very let's
say million degrees
um uh thing um
to be able to to get its nuclei to smash
together hard enough to fuse to release
energy
okay so how do you do that well the only
way one knows to do that is using
magnetic fields
to confine the plasma so there's no
physical material
you know the highest temperatures i
think uh what is it it's um
i think tungsten is actually up there
it's not actually the winner
for the highest temperature um uh
melting point but it's like 6000 degrees
centigrade or something
it's tiny compared to the temperatures
that you need
to uh get enough energy to make nuclear
fusion happen
so you need something other than a
physical material to contain
uh the the plasma for nuclear fusion and
the only way people figured out to do
that is use magnetic fields
the problem is to make something which
is like a bottle a magnetic bottle where
there's magnetic field all around
is really hard i mean you have a bar
magnet and it has a certain magnetic
field that comes out of it
but it doesn't enclose anything so
making a magnetic field that is
successfully encloses things is really
difficult
there are two basic schemes that are the
so-called token hacks and stellarators
which are two different weird shapes of
magnetic field they're weird weird weird
shapes
that try to arrange it so that not only
were a couple of
many different problems but but one of
them is sort of have a magnetic field
which sort of can contain things
and then have it be the case that as the
particles that they're typically
they're doughnut-shaped things they're
ring-shaped things
um as the as the particles go around
these rings
that they not uh come back to the same
place again in such a way that the
it's kind of like a like when you're if
you're on a swing and you're
sort of pumping yourself on the swing um
you're
you're
you know you're making your legs move um
and sort of uh to in resonance with the
time when the swing
comes to the right place well the same
thing can happen in a plasma
but it's really bad in a plasma because
instead of making on a swing you might
make yourself go higher by doing that
kind of
pumping thing but in a plasma the uh if
if these particles sort of
pump themselves they eventually just go
go in the wrong direction and they
escape the magnetic bubble
the magnetic bottle that's been created
so anyway people have been trying to do
a controlled fusion for power stations
for about 60 years
um there are there's a big effort in the
south of france called it
that's a big many country effort to make
a giant
uh version of this that might be ready
in the 2030s it's not clear it's been
postponed several times
there are also now about 20 companies uh
startup companies around the world
that say we're going to do nuclear
fission fusion we're really going to
make it work this time
and uh i hope it does work because if it
does work it's very it's very nice
because
uh the the the fuel source for nuclear
fusion is just
hydrogen which you can get from water
it's it's a completely renewable
fuel and it's sort of uh perfect clean
energy so to speak the only problem is
you have to have to make it work
there was a hope about 20 years ago that
it might be possible to do cold fusion
to make it to make see the problem of
fusion is
if you can ram two protons together hard
enough
they will essentially stick and more or
less turn into a
helium nucleus um but uh
you have to ram them together really
hard and why do you have to ram together
really hard well
uh because they're electrically charged
things they have both have plus
a positive charge and like charges repel
and so when two protons you just get and
go closer and closer and closer
they'll they'll just bounce away from
each other because of their electric
charge
and so you have to ram them together
hard enough that you can
break through the kind of um barrier
associated with the the forces from
their electric charge
to have them actually stick and i think
i talked another time about the strong
nuclear force
which is the force that that holds the
um
the uh protons and neutrons in a nucleus
together
okay so it was a one time about 20 years
ago there was an idea that it might be
possible to do cold fusion
instead of instead of getting these
things to to uh
combine by just ramming them together
really by making them at a very high
temperature where they're going very
fast
that there might be a way to make fusion
happen
by for example what was used was a
material called palladium an element
called palladium
similar to silver um and palladium has
the feature that hydrogen
dissolves in palladium like you think
you put you know
sugar into water or something it will
dissolve salt into water it dissolves
um but you can also have a gas
effectively dissolve
in a solid and that's what happens in
hydrogen gas and palladium
and palladium kind of soaks in tons and
tons and tons of hydrogen
and so it seemed like it might be the
case that it was soaking so much
hydrogen in
that these hydrogens were getting sort
of stuffed in so hard
that they might get close enough that
they could actually undergo nuclear
fusion
but it doesn't seem like that effect is
large enough to be important
and um uh it was um uh
it kind of has a sort of um uh the
attempts to
to make that work have have so far
failed
okay so the question you might
then ask is uh why
why is it possible to get energy both by
fusing together small nuclei and by
breaking apart large nuclei
and the answer is it's kind of subtle um
and it has to do with
the um different well let's see let's
see if i can figure this out
um okay
so there are effects from the bulk and
their effects from the surface of the
nucleus
and well the end result is there's a
curve
that basically just shows the so-called
binding energy per nucleon
the amount of energy that's that is
that sticks together the nucleus um
as as a function of how big the nucleus
is and the the
um the maximum binding energy per
nucleon
is for the isotope iron 56 isotope of
iron
that has 56 total protons and neutrons
that's
the nucleus which is the most tightly
bound together
and every other nucleus is less tightly
bound together so
what happens is is you have this curve
that says you know hydrogen is less
tightly bound than helium which is less
tightly bound than lithium et cetera et
cetera et cetera
what does this mean this means if you
could only take pieces of hydrogen
and stick them together they would be
the result will be more
tightly bound than than the things that
started from what does it mean that it's
more tightly bound well it means that
it is it is kind of uh it you get
you get energy as a result of the fact
that
you go from the state where so let me
give you an analogy
um if you have um
something if you have two planets and
they are
going to be and they can no two stars
and the stars can get captured by each
other and go into orbit as a binary star
system
that that that they're being pulled
together by the force of gravity
and the um uh the result
well this is a little bit tricky once um
this this requires that i kind of
explain some stuff about potential
energy versus kinetic energy and so on
let me let me not go so far down this
path let me just say that that
the the basic point is if you have more
binding energy
then uh you are if if you go from a
state with less binding energy to a
state with more binding energy
you can release energy as kinetic energy
of motion
because as you conserve energy
some of the energy is being used just
bind these things together
and so some other energy can get
released as kinetic energy more or less
um the amount of energy that's released
is kind of
it's kind of like converting a piece of
the mass of the nucleus
into energy and so there's that friendly
formula e equals m c squared
energy is equal to the mass times the
speed of light squared
that's um albert einstein's famous
formula
and that tells you sort of how much
energy will be released
as you uh it's sort of the trade-off as
the
as the as the effective mass now this is
a little bit complicated because
you can kind of read off from the
periodic table when you read off the
line
that says atomic mass and you work out
uh atomic mass gives you the kind of
mass after you take a counter binding
energy
and so by just looking at those values
you can figure out this thing that i'm
telling you
about the fact that the binding energy
per nucleon per proton neutron
is is maximum for 156 and goes down both
for smaller nuclei
and for larger nuclei so that means if
you are a smaller nucleus
and you can combine to make a bigger
nucleus you can use up that binding
energy
to make actual energy you can release
energy by combining these nuclei
together and similarly on the other side
um because the uh binding energy goes
down as you go to bigger nuclei
um for big nuclei that means that by
taking a big nucleus and splitting it in
a smaller nuclei
you can again get energy in going in
that direction
so in uh you know we humans have made
nuclear fission
first down in 1945 i guess
maybe 44 40 1945-ish
um the uh was um
actually maybe maybe the first
controlled fission was slightly before
that
um um early 1940s um in any case
we we humans made fission happen
for ourselves some amount of
spontaneous fission is happening in fact
the way we got
started with with fission as created
by by humans was using natural fission
because some big nuclei particularly uh
uh uranium-235 isotope 235 of uranium
um has the feature that it undergoes
spontaneous fission so you take a
uranium-235 nucleus it's got 235 protons
and neutrons in it
92 protons and 235 minus 92 neutrons
and uranium-235 is unstable it it just
falls apart
but it takes it on average a billion
years to fall apart
more than a billion years and so
that means that uranium that was created
when the earth was created
four and a half billion years ago
there's uranium that was created
even when the earth was created that's
still around because it hasn't all
decayed yet
because it takes on average billions of
years for a uranium
uh nucleus to to to uh to decay
and it decays by breaking apart through
spontaneous fission
so some amount of fission happens
spontaneously when uranium-235 breaks
apart
it's kind of a messy process it
typically it falls apart into
into two nuclear it's not always the
same two nuclei just sort of
just sort of it doesn't it isn't strong
enough to maintain itself and it just
falls apart okay so that happens
spontaneously
the there's another place where fission
happens um
that is important for for us which is uh
in supernovas
um and uh so in a supernova supernova is
the
a type two supernova is the collapse of
a of a massive star
uh our sun won't won't have a supernova
but if it was bigger than our sun it
if a star bigger than our sun can uh
undergo a supernova
explosion at that sort of at the end of
its life and what happens is
i mentioned the sun is what people say
burning hydrogen it's not burning in the
usual sense of burning
it's undergoing hydrogen in the sun is
undergoing nuclear fusion
turning into helium the sun has a little
bit of helium
turning into things like lithium and and
so on into heavier elements
but what happens is as stars
get as cells are sort of pulled in more
by gravity
they they get more and more helium more
and more lithium and other other
elements in them
but they need more and more to to those
those nuclei have higher charges
and so they need even higher
temperatures to get them to
to uh smoosh together and um and undergo
um uh and undergo nuclear fusion
and so what happens is bigger stars
there's enough kind of gravitational
uh the things get sort of uh pulled
together enough by gravity
if you end up getting those higher
temperatures you can get uh nuclear
fusion
in higher uh of higher uh
higher elements and what happens is at
the end of the
of a big star's life so to speak
there'll come this moment
when the star is collapsing and um it's
it's it's used up a bunch of its
hydrogen it's turned it into heavier
elements but the heavier elements
uh are still sort of bouncing off each
other they don't quite have they don't
quite
get over the potential barrier
associated with charge
but eventually the star will collapse on
itself and it will as it collapses
it will be able to push these things
closer together
and let them undergo nuclear fusion
and what actually happens is the star
collapses and it all happens very
explosively
it collapses collapses collapses and it
speeds up its collapse and in matters of
of i don't know what it is uh years to
days to minutes
um it uh it's collapsing collapsing
collapsing
and eventually it gets to the point
where elements like oxygen and silicon
have been produced and they have their
much heavier elements and those elements
eventually can get um to the point where
the star is sort of pushing them
together enough that they start
undergoing nuclear fusion
and this all happens it all kind of
becomes a runaway process and
kaboom there's a giant explosion and uh
the last one we could see
uh with the naked eye from the earth was
in 1054 a.d
the formation of the crab nebula um i
think it was a
it was the explosion was was intense
enough that i think it made the night
sky bright for a few days
um and uh so it's a very very powerful
explosion
that happens as a result of the sort of
the suddenly
the ability to do nuclear fusion with
these heavier elements okay so
that's how that works but in the process
of that happening in this sort of
runaway
uh nuclear explosion in a supernova
uh there's also um that things run away
so much
that you actually get um formation
of heavy elements through a process that
is essentially a fusion process
so you're going from lighter elements to
heavier elements even though
i said in general heavier elements make
energy
by by breaking apart in a supernova
there's so much energy there
that you can make heavy elements just
from the energy associated with the
supernova
and um that's that's basically how all
the heavy elements
that we have um
and the earth for example were made so
all the gold
that we find on the earth you know gold
occurs in the earth's crust about one in
every um
uh one in every ten billion atoms in the
earth's crust is a gold atom
every one of those gold atoms came from
a supernova
so the the we are if if we had existed
earlier in the history of our universe
we would have been or in the history of
our galaxy for that matter
um our galaxy probably at the beginning
was
sort of had first generation stars that
didn't have a bunch of these heavy
elements
but after there was the first generation
of stars that lasted maybe early
millions of years
and those stars had supernovas and
generated heavy elements that can then
be used and recycled
and so we are you know we are the
ultimate recycling story that our heavy
elements
like gold for example are all in fact
everything above iron 56
is has to be made this way um is uh
are all consequences of um
of essentially supernovas now i should
explain by the way just for sort of
completeness
how did the elements beyond hydrogen
well how how did any of these things get
made well they were made in the early
universe
in the big bang the big bang at the
beginning of the universe the universe
is expanding
at the beginning of the universe the
universe was tiny and was extremely hot
probably in some sense infinitely hot um
and at that temperature you can make all
kinds of things
so one of the big things that got made
was um
maybe a second after the beginning of
the universe
um things were very hot and and
and uh it was when things were
sufficiently hot
even nuclei couldn't hold together but
um eventually nuclei started holding
together
and um the uh uh actually maybe it's
maybe it's more like a few minutes after
the beginning of the universe
yeah maybe a few maybe three or four
minutes after the beginning of the
universe
was sort of the most significant time
for this of when
uh you start forming uh helium nuclei
you can get fusion occurring and you can
form helium nuclei
so one of the big facts in the universe
there's about a quarter as much helium
as there is hydrogen
that was all formed in the first few
minutes of the universe
and that's sort of a fundamental
constant and back a long time ago
um in the early 1980s people started um
i was slightly involved in this this uh
things related to this enterprise of um
trying to figure out
how much uh how much helium would get
produced in the early universe there's
about a quarter as much hydrogen
as you go and look at the heavier
elements less and less and less of those
heavy elements were produced
as you go to heavier in heavy arms less
and less of those things were produced
in the early universe and then the only
way to produce these really heavy
elements ended up being
in things like supernovas so that's a
a uh that's the story of uh nuclear
fusion and nuclear fission
uh okay we got a few oh gosh so many
questions here
um ah
okay there's one fairly simple one here
from
sarsaparilla
what's the difference in regular helium
like in a balloon and helium-3
okay so
uh i mentioned
you have these different kinds of atoms
the periodic table
is basically a catalog of all the
different kinds of atoms that exist
hydrogen helium lithium beryllium boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen fluorine neon
etc etc etc um the
each one of those is a different kind of
atom it's distinguished by the number of
protons in its nucleus
and that number of protons in its
nucleus tells you
the number of electrons that the atom
should have
to to counteract the electric charge of
the protons so
if there's a something with um you know
10 protons in the nucleus
in its simplest form an atom of that
material would have 10 electrons
chemistry works by kind of messing
around with those electrons and
different atoms swapping electrons to
make covalent bonds and things
or different atoms having uh having uh
electrons um that are
displaced to make ionic bonds those
kinds of things
um the uh but so so the story of the
chemical properties of materials
is all about the story of how many
protons they have because that
determines how many electrons they have
and the electrons are what
affect the chemistry of materials okay
but if you look in the nucleus of a of a
um
of an atom it is a bunch of protons
that determines the electric charge of
the atom determines the number of
electrons
plus a bunch of neutrons and the
neutrons are just sort of hanging out
there
coming along for the ride the
neutrons in a nucleus are stable
particles actually if you were to
isolate a neutron
strangely enough it decays in about a
thousand seconds a neutron on its own
it just barely is unstable it decays
into a proton
an electron and an anti-neutrino um and
but that happens in about a thousand
seconds so there are no
you you don't get sort of free neutrons
around the place but you do get neutrons
inside an atom the essentially the
the fact that the thing is bound inside
the atom means that it can't
uh it doesn't there there's no
it would have to usually okay so if you
take the the mass of the proton the mass
of an electron
and the mass of neutrino add them
together that mass is less than the mass
of a neutron
so that means the neutron can turn into
those particles
and the the extra energy associated with
that mass just becomes the kinetic
energy of those particles
but when a neutron is bound inside an
atom
then normally in in any stable atom
the neutron just can't the energy
doesn't work out the binding energy
overcomes the energy that the neutron
would have so the excessive energy
neutron would have to be able to decay
into a proton electron neutron
neutrino and so it can't decay so the
neutron is then stable inside the atom
now in some atoms in some isotopes
there are too many neutrons and when
there are too many neutrons
the neutrons will be able to decay in
more or less the same way a neutron a
free neutron decays
so for example for hydrogen the a single
proton is the simplest
isotope of hydrogen another isotope of
hydrogen
is deuterium which is a proton and a
neutron in the nucleus
the next isotope of hydrogen is called
tritium it's so-called hydrogen three
and um hydrogen three it's called three
because it has three particles in its
nucleus
uh a proton and two neutrons uh tritium
decays with a lifetime of about um i
don't know
15 years or something and um its decay
is it's like one of those neutrons
wasn't attached well enough
and it could still have the energy to
decay so tritium
undergoes what's called beta decay which
is decay by emission of an electron
electrons used to be called beta
particles back in the day um
when they were first being discovered in
the around 1900
um and um so
well actually the story is a little bit
more complicated than that but but
roughly
where beta particles were were when they
were discovered as part of radioactivity
they were it was called beta particles
it was only later realized that beta
beta radiation was electrons being
emitted but anyway so
so tritium decays by essentially one of
its neutrons falling apart into a proton
uh an electron and a neutrino and
neutrino and so that means as that falls
apart what gets
left over is two protons and a neutron
so what's happened is that it's it's
turned into um the the that
tritium hydrogen three has turned into
helium three it's called helium because
it's got two protons that make that
means it's helium
and it's got a neutron as well that
means it's got total of three particles
in its nucleus
so that means it's the an isotope with
a um uh
well a nominal atomic mass of three it
isn't exactly three
but because of because of these binding
energy effects that i'm talking about
but
but it has a a uh um an a
number um that is um that's
just the name of it in nuclear physics
um that
uh usually the the um uh the number of
protons is called z and the number of
protons plus neutrons called a
um the uh um
uh that that um that number is three so
that's an example so
two protons one neutron is helium three
so uh someone's asking about helium
three
and um uh so that's what helium three is
two protons in a neutron
it so happens that for helium there are
two stable isotopes
uh i mentioned for hydrogen there are
two stable isotopes protein which is
just ordinary hydrogen
one proton also deuterium a proton and
neutron
as soon as you get more neutrons it
becomes unstable tritium and then helium
hydrogen 4 is unstable with a much
shorter lifetime and so on
so with helium there are two stable
isotopes
helium-3 and helium-4 helium-4 which is
the more common isotope
is uh two protons and two neutrons um
and that um as soon as you get there are
other isotopes of helium like helium-5
and so on
i don't know of hand what their
lifetimes are but they are unstable
um undoubtedly helium five undergoes
beta decay emitting an electron
um and so on uh so
so helium three is so in a
in your average helium balloon you get
the helium that existed on the earth
which is a mixture of helium-4 and
helium-3
and the ratio of helium-4 and helium-3
was determined pretty much
by the production of helium during the
big bang in the beginning of the
universe
and the ratio is
do i remember i don't remember i'm sorry
um uh yeah but it was um helium 3 is
quite rare compared to helium 4.
um helium uh uh helium is a
as a gas um it's a very
um uh it's a gas that has a
um a lower density
than ordinary air and so helium
floats on air so if you make a balloon
that's full of helium
then the balloon most of its mass is the
helium inside it it will float on air so
to speak
um so it will go up in in the air and
the reason
there isn't more helium around here is
because helium
if there was any helium in the earth's
atmosphere it would float
up and eventually escape from the
atmosphere earth's gravity is not strong
enough
to pull down helium so to speak and the
same is true on most other planets but
for example on jupiter
and saturn and so on the big planets uh
jupiter jupiter has enough mass
has enough gravity that helium does not
escape
from the gravitational field of jupiter
so the the atmosphere of jupiter is is
full of hydrogen and helium
which don't escape because of there's
enough gravity
in um on jupiter to prevent those things
from escaping on the earth there isn't
enough gravity and it escapes
so uh and and to get to find helium
on the earth it's it's trapped in rocks
um from when the from when the earth was
originally formed
um i think there's probably a lot of
helium to be mined from the earth but
people sometimes worry that we're going
to run out
um i knew some people who had a rather
peculiar scheme that involved
mining helium-3 from the moon i don't
completely know why this makes sense
because i think there's plenty of it on
the earth that you just have to dig
deeper in the rocks
but i'm not sure um helium-4 and
helium-3
have a number of interesting differences
usually different isotopes behave
chemically exactly the same they usually
a lot of their properties are really
very much the same
um for the very like for example if you
look at i don't know
tungsten or something my favorite
element element number 74 it's my
favorite element because
if you look on a periodic table the
chemical symbol for tungsten is w
because in many languages the name for
tungsten is wolfram or
or some some variant of that and um
no it was not a distant relative of mine
who discovered
tungsten um although i was disappointed
when i was a kid that
um uh it's one of many reasons that i
didn't go into chemistry you know this
is
this is a silly story and not really
true but but um it says it's a it's a
it's one of those could be true stories
but isn't
is like uh it's like i realized if i'm
you know no no chemical element could
ever be named after me
because uh there's already tungsten
element 74
which is already has symbol w and is
already called wolfram
in many countries um it's uh
um you know actually the the general
rule about having
uh elements named after you some of the
some of the uh the very heavy elements
that are now being discovered element
110 elements uh
et cetera these are named after people
but generally the rule had been
you don't get an element named after you
until you're dead
um although i think for glenn seborg an
exception was made for siborgium which
is
element 116 maybe something like that
um the uh but any case most of the um
uh you know there are elements named
einsteinium
uh laurencium named after um
ernest lorenz who was very much involved
in these things
uh mike nerium named after lisa meitner
who was involved in
the whole nuclear fission uh business
there are a bunch of
bunch of elements named after people who
are involved in the sort of nuclear
business in the 1930s and 1940s
but in any case um so uh
what was i going to say i was i was
talking about some uh sorry that was a
that was an irrelevant segway i i am
a irrelevant digression i i have to say
one of the things that
has happened to me at least in the past
is um
uh because tungsten is um
as often is called wolfram in many
languages um
it's uh if i meet people who are from
who don't know english that well and uh
they certainly don't know the name for
tungsten in english
and um i remember
meeting people from from various
countries um in the past who were
involved
in in in uh let's say the government or
business in those countries
and they you know saw
my name or the name of my company which
happens to be wall from research
and they're like they'd start talking to
me about tungsten mining
and it's like uh no no no that's just my
name it has nothing to do with tungsten
really it's not and um and i think i
also i get a certain amount of spam of
people trying to sell me
various kinds of tungsten tungsten
type things because of that also
anyway that was irrelevant an element
like tungsten has a whole bunch of
stable isotopes maybe five or so i don't
remember exactly how many
for tungsten as you get up to these
heavier elements there tend to be more
stable isotopes
at least for a while um until after
uranium when there aren't any when the
elements don't have
any stable isotopes at all at least not
none of the elements we know of
have any stable isotopes after that um
so uh but when you're down
at the uh the light elements there are
modest number of stable isotopes maybe a
couple
now normally with different isotopes
there are
very few differences that you can detect
in sort of the everyday
use of the material so for example there
are no chemical differences because the
number of electrons is still the same
there are very few physical differences
because the materials
that you get by just changing the number
of neutrons in the nucleus just don't
differ very much
sometimes people really care about the
difference between two
isotopes for example the isotope
uranium-235
is the isotope you need to make to make
nuclear fission happen
it's undergoes spontaneous fission as i
mentioned uranium-238
is the more common isotope of uranium
and it doesn't do anything useful well
it does do useful things actually
uranium-238 is a very high density
material and for example it's used
sometimes for counterweights i think on
the
on the boeing 747 aircraft there is a
lump of uranium-238
that's used as some kind of
counterweight somewhere in the
in the plane um but it's it's a um
uh it's it's definitely not of interest
for nuclear physics
uh or nuclear uh nuclear power or
nuclear weapons or anything uranium-238
so the problem is when you have natural
uranium it's a mixture
of 235 and 238 and so this is a case
where you really care about which
isotope you've got so you have to
you have to separate those isotopes and
the main way to separate them that's
used are these centrifuges which
spin the thing around them turn it into
a gas
and it turns out that if you have a gas
of uranium-235 and uranium-238
the uranium the uranium-235 goes a
little bit faster
than uranium-238 because it is um
because it has a little bit lower mass
at a given temperature goes a little bit
faster
and in a centrifuge when you spin it
around you can make the uranium-235
uh go to the outside i guess and the
random 238 goes to the inside
and that's how people with great effort
separate
um uranium-235 from uranium-238
and use it to make for nuclear reactors
or nuclear weapons
and so when you hear about countries
that have been trying to
uh to refine uranium to turn it into for
example weapons grade uranium
um it's uh they typically will have big
centrifuges
um that are used for um a gaseous
diffusion
um uh the am i mixing this up a bit
uh no that that's basically correct what
i what i'm saying
um the uh uh
there are a couple of different
processes there's one that just uses
pure diffusion without centrifuges
um the uh during world war ii there were
two different
uh methods that were tried uh for
separating out uranium-235
for for um for early nuclear weapons
and different places and and they both i
think are still in use
but centrifuges are the most common way
but anyway so usually
isotopes are just all mixed together
they have sort of the same properties
and so on when you get down to the very
light elements
there are some differences like um uh if
you make water
out of deuterium you know water is
usually h2o two hydrogen atoms
and an oxygen atom um you can substitute
for the hydrogen you can substitute
deuterium
and for example you can get like d2o
which is
um uh two deuterium atoms and oxygen
um and that's so-called heavy water and
heavy water actually has a bunch of uses
in nuclear reactors and things like that
um and
uh heavy water uh has um
uh heavy water is actually sufficiently
chemically different
that heavy water is is poisonous to
to us and other organisms if at least if
you have if you just
have a little bit of heavy water it
doesn't really do anything but if you
have
um um a uh a whole bunch of heavy water
and you start having heavy water
substitute for the ordinary water in
inside you uh the the usual biochemical
reactions that make us go
stop working with heavy water so it's a
case where there's a chemical difference
between
between heavy water and light water
so for helium helium-3 and helium-4 do
have some
very interesting differences um
okay i i will explain uh let me not go
into this in too much detail but
most materials when you cool them down
eventually they become
you know that let's say you have a gas
like i don't know oxygen in the air
you cool it down when it's sufficiently
cold it will turn into a liquid
you get liquid oxygen when you cool it
even further down it will become a solid
and then it's a solid okay so
most materials have that property
there's you cool them down
they turn from gas to liquid to solid
um sometimes they go straight from gas
to solid but in the end when they're
cold enough they're always a solid
and that happens because the atoms and
the material they you know temperature
is making them bounce around
um but when the temperature is low
enough they're just not moving very fast
and so the forces that bind the atoms
together are strong enough
that they can eventually that they can
keep keep the atoms
uh in in a rigid solid
well the um as you as you make the
temperature lower and lower and lower
temperature is the average kinetic
energy of materials
of atoms and so when the temperature
goes down goes down goes down eventually
to absolute zero of temperature
minus 273.16 degrees centigrade
at that temperature there is no more
there's no more kinetic energy left the
atoms are just
stopped well they would be stopped
were it not for a fairly subtle effect
in quantum mechanics
uh called zero point energy and zero
point energy
is a consequence of the fact that in
quantum mechanics
um kind of you you in
a limited period of time you can't
constrain the energy of something to be
precisely a particular value there is
always some uncertainty in the energy
and that manifests itself in this
so-called zero-point energy
that exists independent of temperature
so even if the temperature is absolute
zero
there's still some zero-point energy
okay
helium-4 is the unique known material
that has the property that zero-point
energy
the zero-point energy is sufficiently
great in it
that it never becomes a solid at
ordinary pressures
so helium-4 even at absolute zero
helium-4 is uh is still a liquid
um so that's some
uh and okay so and one feature of it is
a liquid it has a very strange property
it's a so-called superfluid and so what
happens is
in let's see
basically it's another phenomenon of
quantum mechanics and it's a phenomenon
very similar to where laser works
a laser is kind of a like a superfluid
but with photons
and the way a laser i think i talked
about this another time the way a laser
uh works sort of all the photons in a
laser all want to get in the same state
and they all want to kind of be all
going in the same direction at the same
with the same color et cetera et cetera
et cetera
um they all want to get together that's
because of the
property of of photons as quantum
mechanical particles they are
even they're they're integer spin
particles okay so
uh helium-4 like
uh photons are what are called bosons
they're particles the helium-4 nucleus
has
two protons two neutrons each one has
a spin of a half and together
the whole thing the spin's actually
anti-align so the spin of the whole
thing is actually zero
and that's an integer and that integer
spin means that the thing is what's
called a boson
and that means that the um uh bosons
have this property that they always like
to get together
and they always like to to fermions the
other kind of thing which happens with
half hundred just spins
um they always like to be they ex they
have
follow a thing called the exclusion
principle and they like to kind of stay
in different states but bosons like to
collect together
so if you have a liquid where all the
atoms in it like to collect together
and they like to sort of be doing the
same thing what happens
well you have what's called a superfluid
and a superfluid
once you start the thing moving all the
atoms will together coherently move
and the viscosity which usually slows
down the motion of fluids by sort of a
friction
among atoms just doesn't operate instead
it's just all these atoms are
collectively just moving moving moving
and they keep moving so superfluid
helium 4
has this property you can startle vortex
in superfluid helium
4 and if you start a little vortex in
water or something like that it will
it will slowly decay out because of
viscosity
in superfluid helium 4 that does not
happen the vortex would just keep going
for months
and it'll just keep circulating in the
in the superfluid um
and that happens below a certain
temperature the so-called lambda
temperature of
helium which is a few degrees kelvin a
few degrees above absolute zero
two point something degrees kelvin i
think
kelvins um a few degrees above absolute
zero
uh helium-4 it's always a liquid
um but it makes this transition to being
a superfluid
um so it doesn't uh
as a superfluid it has no viscosity it
has uh
you can get these things that circulate
forever all kinds of cool things like
that
okay actually what happens is superfluid
uh above the below the lambda
temperature some fraction of the of
liquid helium
is super fluid and the fraction
increases you go towards absolute zero
but
but non-zero fraction becomes superfluid
at the lambda point
the then um okay so what does this have
to do with helium three well helium-3
doesn't have uh it has just three
particles each with spin a half
so the resulting spin of a helium-3
nucleus i don't actually know but i'm
going to guess it's a half
um the uh um but
anyway it isn't an integer and so that
means that
it isn't one of these bosons which has
the property that likes to get together
instead it's a fermion
which likes to exclude things and so it
doesn't have this property
of making a superfluid or at least you
might not think it would
except for a very weird effect which is
that
uh pairs of of helium-3
atoms can collect together and as a pair
they can make a boson and so they can
make a um
a a superfluid as well
and in fact there are two phases of the
superfluid one in which
the spins are are aligned parallel one
which they're anti-parallel
um in the so-called a phase of
superfluid helium-3
um you get this very weird effect where
the where the
where these little pairs of atoms in the
superfluid
have a net spin and that leads to all
kinds of weird
weird effects including one that i
thought would allow one perhaps
uh to detect neutrinos from the nuclear
reactors of nuclear submarines
from or satellites in orbit but
fortunately perhaps it doesn't work
but that would be a different story all
right oh so many questions here i'm
sorry i i take
these these questions are kind of hard
to answer so it takes me a little while
to
to answer some of them um
there's a question here can you explain
the physics of why
ice is slippery um
slipperiness is a very slippery matter
uh when you have two solids where you
have
solids you just put them together in
space
where there's where there's well when
there's no atmosphere in a vacuum where
there's no coating of anything
often two solids will just fuse together
the atoms and the
two surfaces will end up being close
enough together
that it's as if the atoms were seeing
atoms that were already in the same
piece of solid and they'll just bind
together and make the whole thing one
sort of fused together solid
um but uh normally
in um when we're you know on earth in
the atmosphere and so on
there's enough of a coating of um
uh of various kinds of um
gases and things on the surface in
addition the surface tends not to be
perfectly smooth so the surface tends to
have sort of a
craggy sort of microscopic mountain
scape um which causes the
the area of contact between the two
surfaces not to be big enough
for them to really fuse together very
well but in the case of ice when ice
gets slippery
the the thing that that happens there is
that you have a layer of water
liquid water and it acts like a
lubricant it's just like when you have
oil or something you have two cogs and
they're both solid and they're
they're grinding against each other if
you want them to not
grind as badly you put oil a liquid
lubricant
in between them and then whenever
there's sort of a space for between the
the oil will have um so i should explain
one of the defining features of a solid
is the atoms in it originally arranged
a defining feature of a liquid is the
atoms in it can kind of slide past each
other that's why
you can have shear in a liquid you can
you can take you can take a liquid
you can just sort of slide one part of
it relative to the other whereas you
can't do that
at least not easily with a solid so so
that's why liquids
can once you have atoms which are in
liquid form
they will behave like a lubricant and
they'll be able to make things slippery
and that's what's happening in ice when
it gets slippery is there's a layer of
liquid water
on top um that uh produces the
the slipperiness um i i think that the
uh
um i'm kind of wondering whether there's
any other effect that goes on with ice
ice is a complicated material so you
think there's just water there's ice but
there's actually many different forms of
ice the atoms
inside the ice can be arranged in a
variety of different ways
so for example ordinary ice the atoms
are arranged in a hexagonal way
but there are different forms of ice and
depending on the pressure
that the ice is under so for example in
a glacier where there's ice under very
high pressures
you can get different forms of ice i
think there are maybe on the order of 10
different crystal arrangements different
arrangements of atoms in ice
that are known that happen at different
pressures and temperatures
and so on uh in snowflakes you kind of
get to see the hexagonal structure of
ice and
snowflakes aren't quite like a bulk
phase of ice because they're kind of
they're kind of you're seeing the
surface of a snowflake the surface is
important as well
uh let's see
questions oh my gosh so many questions
here
oh boy
um
let's see i'm going to pick a random
question here because there's so many
interesting ones here
this is from sort of relevant to what
we've been talking about from gandra
gandra hunter um uh
can i explain the vanderwaals force
okay let's see if i can do this
so if you have
two atoms that just
happily hanging out the two atoms they
will have a small force of attraction
between them
and um even though that so so
if if atoms had had some of their
electrons missing or
or something they could have a very
strong force of attraction
by electrical forces they can have one
of them could have an electric charge
and that they could they could both have
electric charges and the electric
charges will produce strong forces
between them
but if they're neutral atoms with equal
numbers of electrons and protons in them
they won't have an electric charge they
won't have the ability
to to attract each other and that's a
direct electrical way
okay a tricky thing that happens so
you can have what's called an electric
dipole
so electric dipole is something where
you have some plus charge up here
and some minus charge down here you've
separated out these charges the total
charge of the whole thing is still zero
but there's the the there's plus charge
here a minus an
a compensating amount of minus charge
here well if you imagine two electric
dipoles
you've got a little bit of plus charge a
little bit of minus charge you've got
two electric dipoles
well if the minus part of one electric
dipole can kind of
see the plus part of the other electric
dipole
then it'll get attracted to that and and
vice versa now there'll also be
the it'll be sort of correspondingly
repelled from the other one
but if you work out the math of it it
turns out if you have two electric
dipoles
they will have a force of attraction
between them
um well it's it's it's attraction in
some places repulsion in other places it
depends on the configuration
of the dipoles and so on but um you can
have
a net force of attraction and
roughly the the force of attraction
directly from electricity from electric
forces is is
goes like one over r squared inverse
square it's
as the distance increases the distance
is r
you take the square of the distance one
over that is the force of attraction
for a dipole the force of attraction is
one over r cubed
um and uh but so it falls off more
quickly
but there's still a force of attraction
okay
tricky thing about atoms so an atom will
be electrically neutral
but there'll be a as a result of quantum
mechanics
there are little tiny fluctuations in
which there's
in which basically the electrons are
kind of deforming so they're a little
bit it'll make a little dipole and it'll
disappear make a little dipole disappear
it'll be continually fluctuating around
but there's a little bit of polarization
of the charge to make a little bit of an
electric dipole and that's always
happening
in even in a neutral atom which is
otherwise
otherwise electrically neutral so
imagine you have an atom
that has that sort of fluctuating dipole
that
inside it well it turns out that
fluctuating dipole when when one atom
has a dipole an electric dipole moment
as it's called
that will induce that will cause another
atom
to kind of have its plus and minus
charges separate out a little bit
the forces from one dipole will cause a
force
of forces to make the other dipole
make the other atom have some dipole uh
associated with it
okay so the effect of the first atom on
the second atom
uh is a one over r cubed effect it's
cause it's a dipole force
from one atom to the other okay but so
that atom
kind of makes its own friend because it
it kind of has created a dipole moment
this
this atom over here is is fluctuating
and temporarily having a dipole moment
it causes the dipole moment to happen in
the atom over here
and uh then they both got dipole moments
because this one's fluctuating this
one's had an induced dipole moment
and then there's a force because there
are two dipoles there's a force between
these atoms
and so when you work it out there's a
one over r cubed
effect from the original fluctuating
atom on the other one
then the other atom its force relative
to the first one is another one over r
cubed so the result
is a one over r to the sixth force law
and so
when atoms the typical forces between
atoms
are roughly like 1 over r to the power
6.
actually it's a little trickier than
that um
what happens is the effect of one atom
on the other
can propagate only at the speed of light
and as a result of relativity theory
it turns out that it is actually one
over art of the seventh force law rather
than one over r to the sixth
because essentially by the time the
effect of one dipole one dipole has on
the other
has happened the the um uh there's been
a a sort of a
it took some time for that effect to
happen and by the time
it sort of feeds back to the to have a
force on the other thing
the dipole has changed a bit and the
result of that is that it goes from one
over to the six to one of art and seven
but so roughly there's there's that kind
of force
between even neutral atoms and there's a
when you try and work out
to try and approximate you know what is
the force between atoms well there's a
there's a force of attraction
if you try and do them do the sort of
simulation of a solid
there's a force of attraction that's
about one over r to the sixth
when atoms get very close together they
tend to repel each other
uh mainly as a result of this exclusion
principle thing that i mentioned where
the electrons
don't want to be sort of smooshed
together and that's a one over r to the
twelfth effect more or less
so roughly the the sort of uh
forces between atoms are like one over r
to the six minus one over r to the
twelfth roughly
so there's there's a range in which they
attract and then there's a sort of hard
core in which they repel
and when you look at atoms in a solid
they're pretty much sitting
in that minimum but where the one over r
to the sixth force law is causing them
to be pulled together
but they haven't yet been pushed apart
by the one of our the twelfth force law
that's called for people who who follow
these things it's called the leonard
jones potential
is this one over r to the six minus one
of r to the twelfth type potential
between atoms so that was a little bit
technical but that's that's a um
it's a description of van der waals
forces um
let's see uh
my gosh so many questions here um
oh boy here's one i can do easily from
bean um
i recently drew a social network from
in graph 3d in mathematica but when i
put in more than 200 nodes all my nodes
became blue
is this a bug no it's not it's a
it's a setting for if you look at the
options for graph 3d
it's one of the settings it tries to not
burn your computer alive
um by having it try to draw a huge
number of very elaborately drawn
um spherical nodes there's a setting to
to do that um
i'm going to answer just a couple of
other questions here
um there's a question here from the
chemist
um sort of in the theme of some of the
other ones i've been answering today
question is does quantum mechanical
tunnelling play much of a role in
nuclear fusion
right so it's a little bit complicated
but i'm going to try to explain a little
bit
yeah okay let's see if i can do this
okay so if you try and roll a ball
up a hill if you
if you have give the ball enough
momentum
you can you can imagine if you make the
ball go fast enough
then for a certain height of hill the
ball will get to the top of the hill and
roll over
if you don't give the hill enough the
ball enough momentum
it won't get to the top of the hill it
will just stop and maybe it'll start
rolling back down again
okay so in ordinary physics to get over
a barrier like a hill for example you
have to give something a bunch of energy
or momentum
you have to be having it go fast enough
that it gets over
the barrier of that hill and there's a
definite energy at which
it will get over the barrier based on
the height of the
barrier the mass of the thing etcetera
etcetera etcetera
okay in quantum mechanics
the the main defining feature of quantum
mechanics is it's not
a theory in which only definite things
happen
it's a theory in which there's a whole
branching collection of different
possible things that might happen
and the things that we see happen
are just a particular choice of those
things which might have happened
and by the way in our theory of physics
we have a much tighter view of how
quantum mechanics works
and in fact the phenomenon you're asking
about tunneling
it's actually an interesting thing for
us to look at in the context of our
theory of physics
and i think i can explain to you how
tunnelling works in a way
that but i haven't actually formally
done this with our theory of physics i
haven't we haven't looked at that
phenomenon
yet and we should um the uh but in any
case in quantum mechanics
this picture of the ball is being pushed
up the hill will it get to the top
does it have enough energy uh it either
in classical mechanics it either does or
it doesn't in quantum mechanics
the the ball is effectively testing out
many different parts many different
things that could have happened
okay so some of those things involve
the ball having uh managed to just go
through the barrier
ignoring the fact that it didn't have
enough energy to go through the barrier
now in our theory of physics um
what's happening is there are uh
paths of history that branch out in this
thing we call branchial space
which is kind of a a thing like physical
space except
not like physical space it's a space of
quantum possibilities
instead of the physical space of
positions that we're used to
so in this branchial space what's
happening is
that some of the possible uh things that
could happen to your ball
are actually going through the barrier
and coming out the other side
well it turns out that
uh in in quantum mechanics you can have
a certain probability
for even though the ball wouldn't
classically make it to the top of the
barrier and go over
even though it wouldn't do that there's
still a certain probability that it will
get through the barrier
okay that probability turns out to be as
you as you
increase the the energy difference
associated with the barrier
it's an exponentially small probability
that it makes it through the barrier
and um uh as the as the energy
difference increases
it becomes exponentially much smaller
the probability for it to make it
through the barrier
so in nuclear fusion for example the
question of whether
when you if you want two protons to be
able to really smoosh themselves
together
they have to get over this barrier
associated with the force of repulsion
from electricity from the two protons
and so one way that can happen is
through tunneling
this process of quantum mechanical
process where with some
exponentially small probability the the
protons can just end up
getting through the barrier and and
coming together
uh some uh what's a good example of an
alpha matter
i think americium 241 which is the um
uh uh which is the isotope that is found
in
this used to be found in smoke detectors
i don't think it is anymore
um it was uh was americium-241 which i
believe is an alpha emitter
it's a um uh um it's a
it's an element which decays by emitting
alpha particles which are these helium
four nuclei
and one of the really weird things about
alpha emitters is that some of them have
lifetimes
of a billionth of a second and some of
them have lifetimes of a billion years
so a huge range of different lifetimes
all associated with just spitting out an
alpha particle from a nucleus
and the reason there's such a big range
of variation of lifetimes
is because that decay is happening
through quantum tunneling
and the um uh and the chance of quantum
tunneling
varies exponentially with this energy
difference so even though the energy
differences may not be that great
the the probabilities differ
exponentially with that energy
difference and that exponential change
of probabilities
is what leads to this very wide range of
different um uh lifetimes
um oh there's another simple question
here
uh gosh there's so many interesting
questions here from
pharmaceuticals music they're planning
on releasing the raw data of all the
simple programs
that i generated working on my book a
new kind of science
most of the programs are actually
already in the
uh the notes at the back of the book but
yes we have a systematic project of
going through all of the
code that i wrote for new kind of
science which still runs happily today
and just cleaning it up and and um and
posting it we've kind of been hoping
that um i mean we're uh
we might just make the raw code
available but it's a little bit messy
because it's been set up
specifically to make the pictures that
are in the book um actually just this
morning i was talking about
that as a project for an intern that we
have
to um uh to go through it's been a long
time project
to go through all the code that i
produced in the ten years that i was
working on that book
and and make it um clean and available
um
uh boy you guys are asking so many
interesting questions here
there's a question about muon catalyzed
fusion which i'd love to answer
but i'll we need to keep these from
another time
um there's a question from aram about
when the andromeda galaxy collides with
a milky way
what's going to happen to life on earth
probably nothing much
you know galaxies are very diverse
diffuse except in the center of the
galaxy where there's a big black hole
and quite a high density of stars most
of the time
galaxies just pass through each other
they you know it might be that there'll
be a higher density of stars in our
night sky but i don't think there'll be
much other effect
um
so there's a question here um
i thought i would just answer one or two
more
um
oh gosh there's a question here from
paul what advice would you give someone
who is starting to study analysis from
scratch
i.e from the zamelofrankel axioms and so
on
that's really a question about the
really foundational
theory of mathematics as it happens i am
very actively working on that right now
because what we've discovered is that
there is a tremendous parallelism
between our theory of physics and the
theory of meta mathematics a theory of
sort of the
the structure of mathematics and
mathematical proof and in a sense
as we in mathematics it's kind of
there's this infinite network
of of things that are true of theorems
that are true
and in the physical universe there's
sort of this
infinite space-time network of events
that happen in the history of the
universe
and as the universe evolves we are
sampling more and more of that sort of
infinite network as the field of
mathematics advances with and since
sampling more and more of its infinite
network
and i've been trying to understand the
analogy between these two networks
and the extent to which we can use
thinking from physics
to thought think about mathematics in
bulk
so maybe even by next week i'll have
more to say about that
uh uh check out um when i when i finally
have untangled this i will post
something about it
um
uh there was a question
um
about there's one question i just wanted
to um
uh
it's a question here from gary um
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna try two
more questions here it's a question here
from gary
he says speak about einstein's correct
prediction of the healing of mercury
when people realized einstein's theory
was better than newton's
what might be the equivalent for the
world from physics project
well so history never precisely repeats
itself
so what happened let me tell you the
story of of um
uh einstein's theory of gravity general
relativity
was introduced in 1915 and it's still
writing high as the only and best
theory of gravity that we have and it's
explained all kinds of things like the
merger of black holes that produce
gravitational waves that were observed a
few years ago
all those kinds of things it's done
fantastically well it's had a hard time
being reconciled with quantum mechanics
i think we finally understand how that
reconciliation works
but if we look at the history of
einstein's general theory of relativity
it is a very elegant mathematical theory
when it was first introduced it's like
this is a nice elegant mathematical
theory what does it mean
well there were a few predictions it had
one of the predictions that einstein
really hated
was it predicted that the universe in
its simplest form it predicted the
universe would expand and einstein was
like
that can't possibly be right the
obviously the universe isn't expanding
so he added this piece to his equations
it's called the cosmological term
that was specifically put in there as
kind of a clue
to prevent the universe expanding so
about
a decade and a half later hubble
discovered the expansion of the universe
and
um uh and then einstein was like that
was a big mistake on my part i should
never have added this cosmological term
i should just put put a stake in the
ground and said the universe is going to
be expanding but he wasn't ready to do
that
so there were other predictions so
another prediction that
his theory made was that when light
goes around the sun light feels the
force of gravity
and there was already a prediction from
the pre-existing theory of gravity
newton's theory of gravity
that light will be bent as it goes
around the sun but in einstein's theory
of gravity
he predicted in the end that light will
be bent by a factor of two more
than newton's theory would predict
essentially because
light feels both an electric force an
electric light gravitational force and a
magnetic-like gravitational force
and for light those are equal and so
it's a factor of two difference
okay the first time einstein worked this
out he got a different answer
didn't get factor of two okay so how do
you observe the bending of light around
the sun well during a total solar
eclipse
the disk of the sun is covered and so
when there's a star that comes
just behind the sun you can see that
star
because it's not you're not blinded by
the light of the sun
you can see that star and you can see
was the apparent position of that star
deflected that would correspond to light
from the star having been bent as it
goes around the sun
so the question then is what
uh how much was the light going to be
bent and
there was a total solar eclipse in 1916
and um there was a whole expedition to
go
observe the bending of light around the
sun and test einstein's theory
well uh fortunately for einstein
that was right in the middle of world
war one and it was i think it was in
crimea
part of part of it's geographically
uh in ukraine um the um
uh the um uh the the thing that
um um uh
but in a case it was in the middle of
world war one and
uh needless to i think there was some um
i forget americans maybe on this but i
don't really remember the
full historical details but anyway the
fortunately for einstein
the expedition never never managed to
make an observation there
equipment was impounded by some who
knows what what what happened some messy
thing that happened in the middle of a
war that was going on around people
attempting to observe
light being bent around the sun around
the sun
so uh fortunately for einstein that
observation was never made because at
the time
his calculation of what should happen
was wrong
and what would have happened is people
would have said oh you know even if
they'd observed
like being bent by a factor of two more
they would have said oops einstein's
theory is wrong because it predicts
something different because the
calculation had been done wrong
okay well 1919 comes around that was
after the end of world war one
and a chat called arthur eddington a
british physicist
very keen on you know uh sort of bring
the scientists together even if there
was a war
we're going to you know we british
scientists are going to prove that
um uh you know that german science is is
is predicting good things and so on
we'll do this expedition to south africa
where there was going to be
a total solar eclipse and we'll observe
the benning of light around the sun
probably those experiments were kind of
fudged
probably they they couldn't have done
experiments as as well as they
claimed that they were doing them but
any case that experiment said
great we found it we got exactly the
result the general relativity would
predict
and so um that was sort of a a triumph
for general relativity
there was another effect the advance of
the perihelion of mercury
i'll just explain what that is so when
the earth goes around the sun
uh people say it goes well the earth
goes around the sun and roughly in a
circle
but it isn't exactly a circle it's a
little bit distorted
it's a little bit on the lips and so an
ellipse so the earth is going around the
sun and an ellipse
okay but so an ellipse has sort of an
elongated
uh uh semi-major axis and a semi-minor
axis those are the
analogues of the diameter that if it was
a circle the semi-major axis and
semi-minor axis would be identical
but um they're like the radii the two
different radii of the ellipse
okay so when the earth goes around the
sun to a very good approximation
the ellipse that corresponds the earth
going around the sun is fixed in place
the sun is here
the ellipse is the the the major axis of
the ellipse
does not um does not move at all
it just it's always kept in the earth
just keeps going round and round and
round in this
in this pattern and that's a feature of
inverse square law of gravity if you
have an inverse square law of attraction
the uh it's uh the that has a special
conservation law um that in addition to
conserving energy momentum and again
some things like that it conserves the
thing mathematical name the rangi lens
vector
which is basically says that the um
the the axis of the ellipse always stays
pointed in the same direction the axis
of the ellipse
never changes so that's pretty in a very
close approximation true for the earth
okay mercury the closest planet to the
sun is much closer to the sun
and i i should say that and so
okay i should say that if there's a this
is a feature this preservation
of this direction the major axis of the
ellipse is
a consequence of an inverse square law
of gravity as soon as there's a
deviation from an inverse square
of gravity it's no longer true the the
axis of the ellipse moves over time
it precesses over time okay so
for for the earth very close to an
inverse square law for mercury which is
much closer to the sun
other effects from the gravity of the
sun
can come into it can happen and so
mercury in addition to having a one over
r squared force law for its gravity
has a little bit of one over r cubed
force law as well
and the result of that one over our cube
force law
is that there is a precession in the
ellipse
that corresponds the orbit of mercury
and the perihelion of mercury which is
the the place on the ellipse
where mercury is closest to the sun that
perihelion will process it will move
around
in successive orbits and so that's what
the advance of the
perihelion and mercury is that motion
that change
as in successive orbits of the position
of the perihelion the position of the
closest approach to the sun
for mercury and that advance of the
perihelion is associated with
changes from the inverse square law of
gravity okay
so the inverse square law is
is true for a certain a sphere of mass
and so on
but there are corrections to it when the
gravitational field
has deformations in fact i already
mentioned in talking about dipoles
for electric dipoles there are similar
gravitational effects
and so when you see the perihelion
mercury advancing it's not completely
obvious it's a it's a calculation
it's a complicated piece of astrophysics
to verify that no that's not a feature
of the shape of the sun
it's a feature of changes in the law of
gravity
so that was a little bit of a subtle
thing to untangle
but in any case the um so
one thing that the big sort of message
of this is to make a prediction from a
theory
requires a big stack of calculations on
top of the theory and sometimes those
calculations are hard to do
i mean famously in newton's theory of
gravity newton tried to compute the
motion of the moon
and he managed to get this position of
the
the apps of the moon which is basically
this perihelion type thing
um but but with respect to the earth he
managed to get that wrong by a factor of
two
with his calculations his theory was
correct
but his calculations were wrong and they
were not wrong
in that particular case because he made
some arithmetic mistake
they were wrong because it's just really
hard to do those calculations
and it took 150 more years before people
developed the kind of mathematical tools
to be able to do those calculations well
and to show that newton's theory of
gravity did correctly predict
what had been observed in the motion of
the moon so it's tricky
to get predictions from theories that
can be tested experimentally
it goes far beyond the actual theory
itself in our theory of physics
the the most impressive and spectacular
things that are happening now
are what one might call theoretical
predictions you know there's a there's
hundreds of years of physics that have
been done
particularly impressive physics in the
20th century and
that have led to conclusions like
quantum tunneling
like general artillery like these kinds
of things and the question for our
theory is
can we account for can we use our theory
which has very little that goes into it
and can we do the computations necessary
to get
those features of no and 20th century
physics and that's going spectacularly
well
now can we predict things that weren't
known from 20th century physics yes we
can
unfortunately many of those things
require a scale parameter so for example
when einstein was thinking about the
cosmological constant he didn't know how
big it would be
we still don't completely know how big
it is but it's a it's an extra parameter
in the theory an extra number you have
to put in
so for us we have one extra number which
is the maximum entanglement speed and
physical space
the maximum speed that information can
propagate at is the speed of light
in our branchial space of quantum states
the maximum speed information can
propagate out is this thing we call
maximum entanglement speed we call it
zeta um
and it has we don't know its value we've
got a rough estimate
that its value might be 10 to the five
solar masses per second
um it's in funny units because it's a
funny kind of quantity
um but um we don't know that value
if we knew that value we could make
immediate predictions about all kinds of
things
so with that value we can make
predictions about black hole mergers
the rate how black hole mergers can
happen deviations from what happens
in in uh einsteinian gravity
uh uh as a around black holes a bunch of
different predictions for that
but those predictions depend on this
parameter um
we can also potentially make predictions
about quantum computers if we know that
parameter
um we can show things about the extent
to which quantum computers can work
um they may it still may be the case
that what we're seeing in labs for
quantum computers
is miles and miles away from from the
theoretical prediction limits and so on
i don't know
um there are potentially some
predictions that can be made that are
scale independent that don't depend on
these extra parameters uh ironically
enough i think one of them might have to
do with
photons in orbit around a black hole so
it's very much the same as einstein's
idea
about we've got light going around us a
star but this is a little bit more
ornate
because there's actually photons trapped
in orbit around a black hole
and there is some reason to believe that
when you have pairs of photons trapped
in that kind of orbit
that they will have certain quantum
correlations that simply weren't there
in einstein's theory of gravity but we
haven't worked that out completely and
it's it's non-trivial to work these
things out
so i was i was thinking of writing
something actually about sort of the
stack of what's involved in
is your theory right um because one of
the things that's really cool
with our theory is that um
uh okay so when you compute something
like these two black holes that crashed
into each other
you know a third of the way across the
universe and produced the gravitational
waves that we detected
the computation of that is a complicated
computer calculation actually uses our
uh computational language
a lot in in doing that um when people
actually do that in practice
but um in any case the actual
computation of
of this merger of black holes is a big
complicated thing
where you're taking einstein's equations
for gravity and you're
turning them into a form that computers
can digest
and so you're not just using pure math
to solve those equations you're
digesting them for a computer
and then solving them on a computer okay
so our theory
says there's actually a more direct way
to do it you can go directly from our
theory
which is really a computer-friendly
theory from the beginning
directly go and compute the mergers of
black holes
so it's as if you can you can have a
different approach
to doing that same computation now we
know mathematically
that we should get the same answer at
least if we
if we do the calculation precisely
enough as the one that we get from
general relativity
but both involved for general relativity
we have to
sort of digest it approximate it for a
computer for our theory we have to get a
big version
that sort of approaches what what what
happens for general relativity
and essentially what we're doing is
we're sort of writing a compiler
that goes to we're sort of compiling the
equations of general relativity
down to our model but we can actually
then run the sort of compiled
code in our model to see to see whether
to make predictions like about black
hole mergers
so one of the things i think is going to
happen is that our models
are actually going to provide practical
methods for doing computations
in general relativity and also in
quantum mechanics that are better the
methods we've had before
and so essentially we're going directly
from our model to the answer
even though in the intermediate stage we
know that our model mathematically
should reproduce general relativity
so it's sort of unsurprising that this
works but it is an impressive thing that
we can go directly from our model
without really ever having to talk about
general activity directly to predictions
um and so that's something i think will
happen in practice probably sooner
rather than later
okay i'm gonna answer one more um
and so somebody is okay i'm i'm almost
going to take this challenge somebody is
saying here
that newton doesn't hold a candle to mr
einstein
um you know it's it's a very complicated
thing to to
to discuss the sort of achievements of
different scientists
and how surprising or not they were i
mean the the um
you know and often the
the drama of what they achieved is not
obvious in the later history
so for example for newton the big drama
of what he achieved was
to say you can use fancy math
to work out how things are going to
happen in physics
there was somewhat certain amount of
fancy math before newton
but he said i need even fancier math and
he invented calculus
to uh to figure out what's going to
happen in physics but the big idea was
you can use fancy math to figure out
what's going to happen in physics
einstein some part of what he did
important kind of thing that he did was
to say
you can just reason about things in
physics and figure stuff out
so for example in inventing relativity
you know sort of thought experiments
like
you shine a f you're running at the
speed of light and you shine a
flashlight
how fast does the light from the
flashlight go those kinds of sort of
thought experiments
he thought about things in these kinds
of almost logical ways
and was able to kind of build a theory
that ended up
using some of the current mathematics of
its time to kind of
figure things out in terms of sort of a
logical theory and that was sort of a
new thing at that time
because by then things have been sort of
very much made
made very mathematical i mean i think in
um
uh in the kinds of things we're trying
to do now uh it's sort of a different
paradigm that comes from
ideas about computation that sort of
it's
it's in a sense too easy because once
you really understand that computational
paradigm
you and i'm not sure we completely
really understand it yet but
once you have a a decent understanding
of it
there are things which have just seemed
utterly mysterious before
which now it's like oh well it's kind of
obvious because we know from this sort
of computational paradigm
this is how things work um
let's see i think there was a question
about some
uh sort of a life and times question
which i was just going to end on
oh my gosh what was this okay here's one
from icy um
what gave you the confidence to study
physics since you were a kid
what advice uh would you give have a kid
give a kid interested in learning that
has an internet connection and a
raspberry pi computer
um the main advice i would give
is you know learn this computational
language we've built
that sort of the world's kind of
high-end researchers
use and and we've used to to make the
progress we've made
learn our world from language and
use it to figure out things nobody's
ever figured out before
and because it's a new set of tools
there's just an
unbelievably wide open area of questions
that can be asked
and for example exploring different
simple programs and what they do
i mean i've been doing that now for 40
years and i'm not even
you know a tiny distance into scratching
the surface
of what can be figured out and once you
kind of get the methodology for how to
explore how simple programs work
there's just this vast ocean of things
to understand
and by the way if you do a good job of
that
and you understand something where
you're taking a very simple program and
understanding what it does
it's sort of inevitable that at some
point in the future
maybe even soon somebody's going to say
wow
this thing that i have it's kind of like
this very simple program
and if the program is simple enough it's
sort of inevitable you'll you'll hit it
um that's the thing i have oh somebody
studied how this works
now i understand how the thing that i'm
trying to study works
so it's sort of inevitable if you if you
do a good job of studying a sufficiently
simple program
that it's going to be important for
something in the future
i think in terms of my uh
sort of i think the thing that really
helps in studying
things is just go figure out something
new
and my point is
that you know with this whole
computational language technology stack
it is possible for anybody who learns
that to figure out
something new in a lot of different
areas it's particularly easy
in the sort of abstract exploration of
the computational universe
but you can do it studying data go study
pandemic data go study all kinds of
things
you know there are things you can figure
out because you have
tools that are really giving you sort of
a superpower relative to what people
have had in the past
there is the ability to figure out more
and this is something
summer camp for example uh where it's
like
40 something kids i think we had this
year you can go look on the web
and you can see all the cool things that
kids at our summer camp figured out
um or or did uh and that's in
in a in a couple of week period um and
that's um
kind of an example of yes you know kids
can figure stuff out
you know take your computer out from
languages it's bundled on the raspberry
pi you can it exists on every raspberry
pi just go
start computing things go start
wondering about
questions and just try and see if you
can figure out the answers
maybe you won't know enough to know that
the question you're asking is a question
that was answered 100 years ago
or maybe last year or maybe three weeks
ago or maybe it hasn't been answered
that doesn't really matter the first
thing is just to
get into the habit of being able to use
the tools well enough
that you can answer questions that
haven't been answered before and
you know i've had the the pleasure of
seeing a whole lot of
young people get to the point where they
can do that
and it's really neat it's it's kind of
like a superpower
um and uh i think that the um uh
uh you know that i would say in today's
times that is the best way to get
confidence
about sort of figuring out new things
and doing research and so on
is um uh um is by just
you know doing it there's a very soft
target that's provided by
the computational language that that
we've that we've built
now you know there's also the question
of what what about all that physics you
know do you understand
how i don't know uh the path integral
works or how
um you know the uh grand canonical
ensemble works in statistical mechanics
or how you know all kinds of fancy names
and fancy things and so on
well uh you know as you learn more
it all eventually fits together but it
may take a while to get to the point
where for something like physics it's a
big
old field there's a lot known you know
you won't know every corner of physics
for a long long time i'm sure i don't
know every corner of physics
i know a decent number of corners
because at one time or another i've
been interested in different corners of
physics but i'm sure there are ones i
don't know
um and uh in fact i can already think of
some
um but and for example in mathematics
there are plenty of corners i don't know
mathematics is in some ways
a more diverse bigger subject than
physics it has more
more sort of tentacles that are reached
in different directions
um that probably even than physics has
so for example one thing
i was for a long time afraid of this
thing called category theory
which is a very a very kind of formal
pure approach to mathematics that
originated
as in the 1950s and 60s even 1940s
but it's become popular uh it's had its
abdom flowed in popularity it's become
popular again
um because of uh a relationship to a
thing called type theory which again is
quite old but has been
again it's become popular because of
thinking about computer languages
and then i think it's actually a bad way
to think about computer languages but
then
as a way of of thinking about certain
kinds of formalization in mathematics
anyway i've been afraid of category
theory for years
and i kind of talked to people about
category theory and they explain all
pieces of category theory
and i don't really get it i haven't
really got it i haven't understood
oh there are these morphisms and there
are functors between
between categories and there are
morphisms within a category and there
are endo functors and there are
groupoids and there are um symmetric
minorital categories and all kinds of
very fancy sounding things
i realized um category theory is very
greek
it has a lot of words in it that have
greek roots which is kind of nice
actually i really
like the words of category theory i just
haven't understood what they meant
before
well i'm happy to say that finally i
think in this past week actually
i finally got up i finally climbed that
hill
i finally think i understand the sort of
the core ideas of category theory
quite well um and it took me a long long
time and it really
what was needed was i kept on hearing
the pieces i kept on studying little
things
it's a theory that's very abstract so if
you if you start off just saying
i'm going to study category theory you
know let me just understand you know the
definition of a morphism
okay why are we making this definition i
don't have a clue
um you you kind of have to work at it a
piece at a time
and and for me i mean i always find a
lot of fun you know i've been
around more years than i than i might
like to
to uh at this point but but you know
i've learned a lot of different things
and the thing that is always remarkable
is when these areas that i just don't
know
and sometimes even these areas i mean
category theory i have to admit i've
been afraid of for a long time
actually quite a lot of professional
mathematicians are afraid of category
theory too
um and there's this process called
categorification that people sometimes
talk about
which is kind of a way of taking ideas
and mathematics
and and putting them in the sort of form
of category theory
um and uh the um
the thing that um uh it's kind of a
it's sort of a scary thing to categorify
things because it makes things very very
very abstract
um and and and very hard to understand
in concrete terms but anyway
i it's to say that that um you know so
this is something where
for me it's like i heard about category
theory first probably
oh 40 something years ago and i've been
kind of meaning to understand it ever
since
and i finally now kind of understand it
i think
um and uh it's sort of interesting how
that can happen and it it like
it did take a while and now that i
understand it i can
you know see a bunch of things in it i
can see how it relates to some of these
things we've been doing in physics
um and uh in fact one of the one of the
sort of higher reaches of category
theory
is this thing called the infinity
groupoid which is kind of a limit
of the you have ordinary category theory
which is okay it's or it's very very
abstract
and then you start going to higher
category theory two categories three
categories four categories eventually
you get to the infinity category
uh and that leads to this infinity
groupoid which is just this super
abstract thing
and and we've realized in recent times
that the infinity groupoid is actually
related to a thing
we call the rule multi-way system which
we invented
as part of our physics theory and that
sort of actually gives one a concrete
understanding the of the infinity group
void
that makes it clear why it's well it
makes it gives an
argument for why it's relevant in in
physics and in mathematics
and there are there's a thing called the
homotopic hypothesis or growth indeed
hypothesis
which is a deeply deeply abstract
hypothesis about the infinity group void
that is looks like we kind of understand
you know
why does this relate to anything and we
kind of understand that now
um or beginning to understand that and
it's it's it's really a neat thing and
it's it's something where
you know just because i didn't
understand category theory for 40 years
doesn't mean i can't understand it now
and um that's uh um
and that's sort of an interesting story
of that
um all right well i think uh
should wrap up now we've saved up a lot
of questions that um
uh we can perhaps um
um go on with um
uh next week
well thanks for thanks for joining me
thanks for asking lots of interesting
questions
you know i hope you guys find this
interesting
i find this really interesting because
you get
you get to ask me things that i have
never explained to anybody before
i get to try and explain them and every
time i explain something i understand a
little bit better
um and uh hopefully hopefully give you
an opportunity to understand some of
these things too
so uh thank you all and look forward to
seeing you again next week